what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today John's
going to be joining me in just a little
bit to do this reaction but before that
I wanted to give a shout out to today's
video sponsor and this is a service that
I personally have been using for several
months and I love them it has been
life-changing for me and that is Master
Class I'm telling you guys it's worth
getting because yes signing up for them
is a great way to support the channel
but really it's just an amazing
investment in yourself here's basically
how it works there's over 180 plus
experts in a variety of subjects
anywhere from like cooking you know
songwriting screenwriting directing
Communications a a wide range of
subjects and they're all from experts
the best way to learn about any subject
is to learn from an expert not long ago
I was speaking with a couple of
filmmakers actually and they were
telling me how masterclass was
life-changing for them specifically the
art of negotiation by Chris Voss they
said it helped them out with business
negotiations and communication skills
just in general and for someone like me
who gets social anxiety in many circles
it actually really helps me out when
communicating among strangers and I was
like all right how much is the program
and then what I found out was and many
people have this misconception is that
when you sign up for Master Class you're
not signing up for just one class you're
getting access to all of the classes and
the classes are usually broken up into
10-minute segments it sometimes I go a
little bit longer but they are all
wonderfully put together easy to digest
you really just become that much more
knowledgeable depending on the subject
that you want to study my passion is in
screenwriting so I ended up taking Aaron
sorkin's screenwriting class and I'm
telling you my creative writing changed
so much I'm currently making my way
through the James Cameron course there's
so many that I'm going to be going
through already and right now they have
a great deal going on that I highly
recommend you check out because this
holiday if you give one annual
membership you get one free so you can
go to masterclass.com rejects once again
that's masterclass.com rejects terms
apply I did this all off the Dome all
off the top of my head because I
genuinely love this program and I'm
telling you it is one of the most
worthwhile Investments I'm excited to
finally be partnering up with them on to
the reaction
[Music]
so you have a movie for me yes sir I do
it's a sequel to a super popular movie
and it's going to have blue people
underwater the Avatar too Marvel doesn't
make those you silly goose actually I'm
talking about Black Panther 2. oh okay
yeah no that series is in our web Patois
that's not how that's pronounced so
anyway obviously we're gonna start the
movie with a nice tribute to Chadwick
Boseman you know the Marvel logo is just
gonna be him of course and in the movie
t'challa is gonna pass away from an
illness and sure he's going to be trying
to save him by making that heart-shaped
herb synthetically but she's not gonna
manage wow yeah so throughout the movie
shuri and the wakandans are kind of
dealing with the passing of t'challa
while also dealing with this new threat
that emerges oh what's the threat oh
it's freaking Neymar Namor no more how
do you pronounce that you know everybody
in the movie is going to say it
differently I guess there's no wrong way
to say it no I'm gonna pronounce it yeah
more okay no maybe there is a wrong way
like a hungry little kid asking for
seconds of his favorite dessert yeah
more is that cool yeah no that's
absolutely not cool
this guy want to fight wakanda oh it's a
long story but see this guy's the leader
of a secret underwater Nation called
talocan and they also have vibranium
right now that's the stuff that makes
all the cool things do all the cool
things and since wakanda told the whole
world about vibranium the CIA started
looking for some with a vibranium
detecting machine what does that machine
do it detects vibranium that's probably
why they called it that that's
absolutely why it's called that sir and
since the CIA found some vibranium
underwater Namor is like hey wakanda
this is your fault what the heck so he's
like now you gotta go get me the
scientist that made the machine I mean
if the machine was purchased by the CIA
they probably already looked into how to
make more what's the point of getting
the scientist girl so we can introduce
Riri Williams to the MCU before her show
premieres on Disney plus oh okay yeah
that is urgent get her in here real
quick you see I've heard this point
brought up many times now many times and
I agree that I feel like the CIA
probably in some way has already made a
vibranium device I feel like there's a
way to replicate it or take it apart and
rebuild it in their own fashion you know
I feel like they're more than capable of
doing what this teenager was able to do
essentially however you know same time
Riri is the creator so
go after the Creator
I look at his Source I'm trying to find
a way to justify it admittedly I don't
have a real reason here you know just
the MCU is just full of brilliant
scientists they're only a couple and if
they don't work for you then you just
can't figure any of that stuff just go
after the way he goes after Ramona he
goes after the god of the machine yeah
there there we go that's what it was
let's go straight to the source every
time so now more just kind of shows up
in wakanda and says this is a Tiffany in
the queen do they not have security for
the waterways headed into wakanda I mean
they must but Neymar's so good he
bypasses them how does he manage that
with his you know water skills I guess
it's off screen so he just comes and
goes as he pleases coming and going as
you please is Ty sure sure so now shuri
and akoye have to go get Riri or wakanda
is going to be attacked I know they said
more backup with them on clear but why
didn't they say why is this an only the
two most important people who aren't
Ramona Mission yeah that's a little I
mean you could have brought at least you
know Nika or a couple of the other uh
Dora melange along Nika uh no no the uh
it's from I may destroy you she's uh you
know aquila's like I think that's their
names you know she's the one who um they
go she's got the two daggers you know
and uh they go to her wrecked house and
she's like I don't want to leave here
and then she's like but we're back and
then she's like what do you need me to
do definitely continue the reaction I
just got so much more to say about these
characters though hold on
[Music]
but so then shuri and Riri get taken to
talocan underwater uh oh tough to
breathe underwater and so no more shows
Sherry how beautiful his nation is and
tells her his origin story and why he
hates everybody understandable I don't
even tell you why he hates everybody I
know I just
I get it okay that's alarming so anyway
he's like hey we should team up and burn
the world down and if you refuse I'm
gonna destroy wakanda first they're
gonna wage war with the entire planet
yeah yeah how do they plan on taking on
landlocked countries with beluga whales
and hot air balloons well I wouldn't
laugh so you know what they say about
beluga whales you never know when
they're gonna strike that's not true it
might be so anyway eventually Nakia
comes and rescues them and they head
back to wakanda nice but then Neymar and
his people are gonna attack and they've
got water they've got fish they've got
really good singers that'll make you
kill yourself and the more has tiny
little wings on his feet oh and then he
drowns the queen oh my God yeah and then
he tells shuri all right I'm gonna give
you guys some time to regroup okay does
a week
oh my God
could catch the battle of the movie okay
so then Sherry freaking figures out how
to synthesize that flower and she
becomes the Black Panther oh wow wow wow
wow can't stop looking at it now
we're getting Suits now that's right sir
several people are kind of Iron Man now
wow and how did they get all that done
in such a short amount of time Montage
gotcha so now it's time for the big
final battle and they figured out their
plan of attack what's their plan they're
gonna head out to the ocean and fight
the ocean guy and his people there isn't
that the enemy's home turf yes isn't
that where the enemy will have the
biggest Advantage oh absolutely that
doesn't seem like the best plan well
that's the one they're going with also
they realize if they dry Neymar they can
weaken him a bit but what are they going
to attack him with a blow dryer no no no
no that'd be ridiculous all right it's
more of like a space heater type thing a
sauna okay so the wakandan said to the
ocean for this fight and you know really
get their butts kicked yeah because
that's where the enemies at their
strongest for sure for sure I do think
that is a good point that I haven't
really thought about directly that like
they do go to like the place where they
have the biggest disadvantage I know you
can't like have I know people said like
why don't you go up to where the Jabari
are and fight there like the fight
wouldn't happen but still it does feel a
little bit like uh you're leaving
yourselves entirely vulnerable without
much of a plan you're on this barge
you're completely surrounded they know
that they have like way more forces than
you do right but they did have a
specific type of ship device that the
bars that they were on it was the sound
cannons yeah and I think that like the
idea was to bait them right to bait them
to coming there they did plan on just
escaping after they caught in a more so
that way they could just leave but then
I don't think what they anticipated
which is probably they should have was
that they could blow up the engines yeah
yeah blowed up the sound bomb things
that they have yeah totally yeah I think
that was part of it was to lure them in
there thinking that they had the
advantage and their plan was to just
leave after they got into more right I
think with my military experts let me
justify them justifying Marvel that's
what we do but Sherry's going to manage
to dry Neymar off a little bit and get
him on land so they're gonna fight while
he's weakened oh great but then she gets
badly impaled you know right through her
oh my god well it's gonna be impossible
for her to beat this guy with that kind
of injury actually it's gonna be super
easy barely an inconvenience oh really
yeah because he checked this out what
she does is she's fine immediately
right away so what about the severe
impaling wound they shut up so then
she's about to kill nanotech they can
heal fast an alliance and he's like oh
yeah okay sure an alliance and she
trusts the word of this guy who just
killed her mom and made that promise
under the threat of death I
yes well great
the Black Panther had a kitten and we're
done what so what do you think well it
sounds like a great movie and a nice
tribute to Chadwick Boseman thank you
yeah this is going to fit right in with
all the other fantastic movies we'll be
releasing in 2022. oh yeah people are
gonna love them all sir
[Music]
wow is it really is that a fact I I
guess that well okay we're certified
first that means above what 80 percent
okay because yeah I feel like there's
got to be one of them in like the seven
like they're not all rotten because this
isn't the eternals the only one that's
rotten this year yeah yeah I think it's
just it's the only one that's like
unanimously pretty well agreed on oh
that is wild it is yeah like especially
seeing it presented that way oh that's
too bad oh well what are you gonna do
this is good though it's a good one that
means it means black panther wakana
forever wins that's right and we got to
see the true origin conversation between
the white writer and the white producer
I thought something was gonna happen
with that whale it's crazy I know is it
still like this is a Randomness middle
Easter egg for us the audience that's so
funny alrighty guys well you managed to
sum up that two hour and 40 minute movie
really fast I know and with an
interesting tone for this pitcher yeah
it was still really funny but it wasn't
as like you know off the walls as you
might I'd expect true true all right
guys well leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that Bell